there's a very special time invest you
can buy stuff later
you got your prospective
[Music]
what I was really doing this press
freedom yes my god which yes I've
completed for now my stress my life is I
just wanted to be an artist just her as
a drum roll not have a boss etc which I
have like seventies megastretch almost
killed us sometimes my wife kept Nick is
nice crazy that's what I had to do a
whole other job four hours a week just
like look I think listen here's what I
would say don't judge yourself either
how old are you you know take into
account that you're 25 right like do you
have a relationship yeah right so like
you know you've got a that's a part of
your life you're 25 like it's okay to
like wanna I'm sure you have other
interests whether it's to watch a film
or a little food or a proper football
team like I don't judge myself during my
whole career when I wanted to maximize
every minute it didn't even cross my
mind that on Sundays 16 times a year I
did nothing but watch the Jets like I
think the thing that people do poorly is
they judge themselves okay so what
you're telling me is at 25 you feel that
your work ethic is a little softer than
when you were forced to yeah but who
says that your work ethic won't be
greater at 32 when you see that
three-dimensional art in on the moon is
a new white space because Elon got us on
the moon so I think too many people
judge themselves I used to think I
worked harder than everyone yeah
when I worked from 7 a.m. to 11 p.m. in
the liquor store but in those hours in
that liquor store and it was more 8 a.m.
let me not even paint the wrong picture
8 a.m. to 10 p.m.
let's actually be more fair in those you
know 14 hours I had downtime compared to
today because technology wasn't the same
way I didn't have an iPhone yeah so like
you know like if four people called out
and I had to be on the actual floor not
on the computer selling wine if nobody
walked in I was kind of stuck maybe I
could like to make some sign
but if I had my phone I could have been
on Instagram and sold wine so where I'm
going is okay good
enjoy the rest because but you
understand yeah yeah look I listen
there's another thing that people don't
talk about talent yeah
athletes some people are just born
unbelievably talented and they don't
have to work as hard and they never do
because they will they can run like a
gazelle yeah right your you know
probably one of the things that your
quantifying and dealing with is you you
know you have talent and so the talent
is maybe allowing you a little freedom
in the work ethic Department yeah
currently if you live in New York City
and you have a Steph Curry Jersey on
that I think you're a piece of [ __ ] I
think you're a piece of [ __ ] not because
you're a bad person I think it's a very
interesting psyche when you pick a team
either based on the history or the
current winning status or when you pick
an underdog why do I hate Kobe Bryant
until the last year of his career when
he's a little more washed up than I root
for him and I'm very interested in when
I started announcing when we open this
office that I wanted to pick a team I'm
fascinated that like 99% of people are
fans of the same four to five teams in
the same way in the u.s. whether it's
the Lakers or you know or baseball the
Yankees the psyche of people that want
to jump on bandwagons
versus the psyche of the people that
want to pick something and pick an
underdog I just basically think that all
of you that jump on good teams when you
live in a town that has a team that
you're actually a loser
thank you
every one of you should do it as early
as you can afford it as early as you can
afford invest invest invest it's a very
special time invest you can buy stuff
later
first prize like a writer yeah what you
want to do into written and audio and
video yeah a writer a post
Caleb's amazing cuz he can film and post
produce and then you want to ask
somebody who knows how to take the audio
and start your podcast 100% written word
audio video the way the world works
the sooner the better animation company
yes I just rented when we were to expand
d wasn't advice on trusting other people
to your vision
it's all ego
either you can stay small and control
everything or you can let go I always
think of it this way if you Caleb does a
bad job I can always fire him yeah I can
coach them up yeah I can say sorry to my
audience you're in control
but it's ego it's what it's the feeling
that you like to think you're the best
next
and that's what keeps people smile
[Music]
Suntech sorry
[Music]
it's funny I don't know what to do with
this one so here's my theory
politics advertising [ __ ] on your
competitor wins that's exactly what
brands should be doing Pepsi's only
moment was the Pepsi challenge coke
sucks when these is effectively hurting
McDonald's right now is [ __ ] on them
every brand if it's not number one
should [ __ ] on number one as their
entire strategy and it will work
[Music]